one of the main streams of my research
for the last more than 10 years have
been focusing on this honesty and
dishonesty is really interesting because
it's not just about dishonesty it's
actually a phenomena that captures
almost all of the human principles of
behavior
it's about selfishness versus generosity
it's about us versus other people it's
about rationalization it really kind of
in captures a lot of things and because
of these there are lots of forces that
drive dishonesty but here is one way to
start thinking about it when we grow up
we grow up in a social environment and
our parents try to teach us what is
acceptable and not acceptable and in
that environment white lies are
certainly acceptable encouraged and our
parents teachers you know as somebody
who was who has a visible disability you
know I see kids from time to time point
in me and say mommy why is this man has
scars and the parents often say it's not
nice to point don't say that I mean
basically right so there is a lot of
things that we teach kids about how to
be polite when being polite of the mean
not saying the exact truth you we teach
them that so this is white lies right
and white lies are not about our benefit
it's about the benefit of others then of
course they are the lies that have our
benefit as well here in New York I think
the subway is probably blamed for lots
of things that they are not responsible
for probably everybody who's ever late
in New York blames the subway for some
reason right they don't say oh you know
I I know we had a meeting I was just I
couldn't care really about getting here
on time I don't know I don't care so
much about you waiting for me so I left
like you don't say that right you say I
left on time it's just a subway you
wouldn't believe what happened right
those are not lies for other people it's
true that they don't offend other people
but they help you as well and then there
are lies that are more and more selfish
over time but the interesting thing is
that we learn to line these social realm
and then when we move to the business
world all of a sudden we're not supposed
to lie but can we make this transition
turns out it's very hard to make this
transition and it's very hard to make
this transit
especially when your social circle and
business circles are overlapping I think
a lot about students at the university
their social cycle which is circle which
is their friends and campus and the
people they work with the people that
they collaborate and do papers with and
so on are the same people the overlap is
is almost perfect can we expect them to
say oh this is a social realm it's ok to
be polite this is a professional realm
left me not so so as those circles
overlap it's become harder and harder to
keep honesty and not to be dishonest the
other thing though is that you know
we've done lots of things in the lab
about dishonesty we got people to steal
money from us and we see when they steal
more and when they still less but in the
last few years I item DUP with the
director and producer al melamed and
we've invited people to come to the
studio people who've committed big
crimes and we asked them to tell us the
stories of what they have done and we
asked them not to say what they did at
the end but to start with the first step
and then talk for hours about how the
first step go to the next step and the
next step and the next step in the next
step and what is so interesting about
those stories is that all by one of
these stories were stories of slippery
slopes there were stories that you look
at the end and you say I can't imagine
doing it but you look at the first step
and you say you know what I understand
the pressures of that particular
situation and under those particulars
you know I might have acted in the same
way as well so as far as dishonesty goes
we're kind of blinded to the forces that
cause us to be dishonest you know we
look at other people say oh my goodness
these are awful people I am really good
but we don't really understand how
pressures work on us and how likely we
could be to just go down take one wrong
step and then go down the slippery slope
just like lots of other people
you